so right up front spoiler warning for
the entire show of Breaking Bad as well
as the final episode obviously yes I
have been keeping a secret from you guys
I have been watching Breaking Bad I
didn't want to tell anyone about it that
much because I knew that everyone would
start freaking out so I actually watched
the entire show in about a month's time
so let me quickly sum up my thoughts on
the entire series holy crap
Bryan Cranston can act Aaron Paul bitch
Skyler's an uptight hypocrite Hanks a
hilarious badass Murray's overbearing
Walt Jr loves pancakes oh my god Gus's
face Todd is Satan this shot Walt /
Heisenberg is one of the best characters
in TV history you're goddamn right so
yes I have finally watched Breaking Bad
I've caught up with the entire show over
the past month so I could watch the last
few episodes and Here I am to talk about
the final episode Felina I got literally
thousands of requests to watch this show
and I'm not just talking about viewers
like you
I'm talking about my personal friends in
real life as well like they just were
like dude why aren't you watching the
show I can tell you why I'm honestly
very glad I waited this long because
there were so many cliffhangers
throughout this show especially between
season 5a and 5b I don't know how you
guys did that it was apparently like a
year what were you guys doing while Hank
was sitting on that toilet taking that
humungous crap for a year how did you
guys even do that I don't know because I
could just click next episode next
episode it was wonderful but last night
what I personally think is the best
straight-up TV drama ever created
finished its run so the episode opens
and Walt has still disappeared no one
knows where he is he has a beard he has
a full head of hair now his cancer has
returned as we've learned in previous
episodes hank is dead all these people
are dead and he's trying to come back to
figure out a way to make everything
right and what I loved about this
episode was that they try to make you
think so many different things are going
to happen and while you know you want
certain things to happen they do happen
and not necessarily in the same way
you've thought like I thought when he
was coming in to see Gretchen and
Elliott that he was going to kill them I
just thought here comes his big revenge
moment but when he revealed that he
wanted to use them to give his children
the money he had earned it made perfect
sense to me because it was a good clue
for those characters but it also makes
it possible for his dream to come true
for his children to get the money he
wants in a way that no one would ever
suspect as suspicious
something I've been wanting to see ever
since season five started is this guy
Todd or Satan as I like to call him he
is just disgusting like the entire show
has really cool villains like Gustavo
Fring is such a great villain he was
interesting he was fun you felt like you
actually cared about him as a person
because you saw his backstory and what
happened to him in the past although you
knew he kind of had to go because of how
bad of a person he was in general this
guy Todd you don't feel a thing for him
he's just this slimy slithery guy
everything out of his mouth just feels
disgusting like it the actor props to
the actor okay because I hated that
character and I cannot wait to see him
check out and I'm so glad it was by
Jesse's hands because that's what I
really wanted to see because he was
basically torturing Jesse and keeping
him in that cage and it was just so
satisfying to see Walt create that
weapon system that took everyone out and
then when the one guy is left and he's
like look I'll tell you where the money
is he just shoots him in the face you
get that blood splat all over the screen
that was fantastic not just because of
the violent element but because he was
like I don't care about the money
anymore I don't care I'm gonna die soon
and this is it I don't care and you need
to die and you need to go right now
the way he slipped the ricin and the
girls drink it was perfect everything in
this finale came together and you could
really feel that the creators of the
show Vince Gilligan and all the writers
had a plan they didn't just start off
some show and like here's a great plot
hopefully we'll go to a cool finish now
these guys
continuously created amazing writing and
terrific episodes all the way through
the show I really don't think there's
one week episode in this show which is
incredibly rare his last conversation
with Skyler was so well handled the fact
that he has to watch Walt Jr through the
glass of this other building it seemed
so bittersweet to me because I was
thinking to myself how are they going to
handle the whole conversation with Walt
Jr if he has one final one he tried to
on the phone and it obviously wasn't
going to work out Walt's last exchange
with Jesse was beautiful it was about as
good as it could possibly be there
wasn't even any words between the two
you could tell the entire story just
through their looks and they did such a
terrific job these two actors and that's
something I gotta mention is Bryan
Cranston truly impressed me
so much with the show because I already
respected him a lot it's an actor from
Malcolm in the Middle and various movies
he's been in but this show just blew me
away this guy's talent and another thing
I love about the show is that the entire
cast is great there isn't like a weak
link where you look and say yeah they
kind of suck that's that's too bad
because everyone else is really good no
I mean like Aaron Paul is absolutely
phenomenal in this show I think he gives
such great performances episode 2
episode and that's one of the things I
loved about this show was how the entire
cast really was just terrific as the
series is drawing to a close I could
tell it would be kind of weird if Walt
somehow lived like he got some magical
cancer readout thing because he's always
going to jail so I wasn't surprised by
his death and I think they did an
excellent job at it because he died in a
meth lab with a bit of a smile on his
face this sort of I'm content smile with
everything that he was able to
accomplish and complete he died where he
wanted to be where he was most
comfortable where he finally admitted
that he was actually there for himself
that he wasn't just doing it only for
his family that he did it for himself
and that was also great because
throughout the entire show you can tell
that he's kind of selfish and in regards
to what he loves he's doing it because
he enjoys it now and it's like when he
first found out that his cancer was
going away and he punched that paper
towel dispenser because he realized I
might not have to do this meth cooking
anymore because now I don't need the
money he was mad because he was starting
to enjoy it and the way they brought
that up again in the finale was really
well done because I knew at some point
he was gonna have to admit something
that it wasn't just his family that he
was doing that for he wanted to do it
for himself too and they did such a
great job with that everything in this
show came to a perfect conclusion here
this was in no way a disappointing
finale that was the one thing I was
worried about because as each episode
was going along I was like man this show
was really really good and I'm getting
into it and I was just marathoning it
like over and over and I was like please
Season Finale be good don't end stupidly
or make Walt have some magical recovery
and everyone's happy and no he's not
going to jail like it was so well done
it was realistic that's what I loved
about this show was it was all realistic
there wasn't that one episode that to me
anyway jump the shark and became silly
or over-the-top everything made sense
and the way it was all put together was
just great it's one of the best TV
dramas I've ever seen personally
probably the best actually I'm gonna
give this final episode as well as
the entire show of Breaking Bad and a
plus so guys what are your thoughts on
Breaking Bad to show what is your
favorite episode or favorite moment in
the entire show let me know below I
think my favorite moment in the entire
show is the finale of crawlspace in
season 4 or Walt just loses it under the
house and he starts laughing like the
Joker guys thanks as always for watching
and thank you Breaking Bad for being a
terrific TV show and as always guys if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes